Oh dr. Wallach thanks for taking my call
I sure wish I've been on your product
yeah I've been on your products about
two months and I'm doing so much better
with my regenerative this but I have I
have two questions for customers okay
one of them well no go ahead sir
well one of one of the situations is for
scapular thoracic Bruce itis it's for a
nineteen-year-old it weighs about 150
pounds okay to get bursitis yes
okay this in his shoulders his hip as
where he got to recite us uh it it's in
his back his scapula okay okay so the
upper vertebrae and the shoulder blades
okay
very good okay now how tall is this kid
he's about five nine okay five-nine I'd
like to see him leave one about 180 so
easily seventy pounds here and Charmaine
you there I'm here I'm here
okay here's a 19 year old kid one of
kavita's customers nitrile kid weigh 250
pounds five nine as a back ends and
problems pain primarily but he's again
at least seventy eighty ninety pounds
overweight and so then we have to deal
with the raw materials necessary to
support promote maintenance repair of
cartilage ligaments tendons connective
tissue disken vertebrae and so on
so what would you suggest for this kid
well I would suggest he gets on a
gluten-free diet and for the issues that
he has I would suggest because of his
weight three healthy bone and joint
packs okay she's healthy bone or joint
tax what else again I would add some
trauma oil to the CM cream that comes
with it for pain and and also I actually
wouldn't hurt him to get on a
teeter-totter thing upside down okay
what would you do first but what you do
for his weight I give on to Ralph
get him on the red very good okay so
there you go kavika okay this kid needs
to get optimally three of the healthy
form and join pack so he only afford to
know lesson two
he needs to get the trommel oil to mix
with the CM cream to put on the back so
you can get really pain and then of
course fifteen gluco gel is 85 a
breakfast spot at lunch five a dinner
time and get the MSM okay from our free
life or news company we've joined the
young Joey family free life and that's
am having takes three those tablets
twice a day about a month